gayle sayers gail sayers the hall of
fame running back absolutely
with the chicago bears uh dynamic
dynamic football player playing on a
team that didn't have a lot going for it
quite honestly
he had him and he could do it all i mean
he could return oh my goodness
he could he could run the ball i mean he
just went as good of all-purpose back
as there's ever been mike michael that's
that's where i wanted to go
so you took the words out of my mouth
because if i were at the press
conference and i think
i think we heard of gail sayre's passing
at 77 i think we heard it
after bill met with the media i believe
i don't know if he was asked about it
today but whenever he's asked about it
you're right that's when bill is at his
best
is talking about pro football history so
i know that he's going to speak
glowingly
about gayle sayers gail sayers is as
good an all-purpose back as there ever
was you hit on it the returner
the returner he might have been as good
of a returner as we as this league ever
saw
he was as brilliant a ball carrier as
anybody who's ever done it
uh 68 games 68 games
because of knee injuries and a first
ballot hall of famer michael he is the
gold standard
for you know it when you see it whenever
we talk about somebody if they're a hall
of famer if their career ended today
we're talking about the gail sayers rule
about like okay
he longevity was not on his side wasn't
his fault me got shredded
but man if nobody was ever better at
running the football still got the
record with six touchdowns against san
francisco in 65.
last thing i'll say about this michael i
think it's the last thing depending on
what you say
i was born in 1979 but i actually did
grow up watching
gail sayers and i'm not talking about
brian's song
i'm not talking about you know billy dee
williams and you know
playing out uh him and uh playing uh
gayle sayers and brian's song
by the way also one of the most
respected and admired men in the nfl
community gail spears
but the reason i say i grew up watching
him is i remember
watching nfl films video with my
grandfather and my
uncle and i remember the clip like i was
like it was yesterday
and it was gail sayers and that grainy
footage looking at the camera saying
give me 18 inches
of daylight that's all i need and next
thing you know it's just this this this
this and this
like i watched this so i watched the
film of him growing up
and so when everybody anybody said
something about the best backs of all
time
if you just talk about pure ability you
got to start with gail sayers
yeah you got to put him in the
conversation and i'm glad you mentioned
that uh and the last thing i'll say
about it too mike
i'm glad you mentioned the nfl films
part of it because it's a great thing
about this era isn't it
that anytime you hear a name that you're
not familiar with anytime you hear about
somebody who's not from your era chances
are
you can go to nfl films youtube anywhere
and look at some of that footage and i
would just recommend for those of you
who
think we're exaggerating about gale
sayers just check them out so uh gail
sayers rest in glory what a wonderful
life and a wonderful career
amen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports